do you guys think modern women need men
hell yeah everybody everybody yeah to
everybody men need women women need men
it's how human beings are designed we're
designed to complement each other and I
think just I don't think men need women
you don't think so why not because they
would survive without us we wouldn't
survive without them they run the
infrastructure of society they do all
the hard jobs if they if we if we
disappeared tomorrow if outside of
reproduction they would keep living
single men are more likely to commit
suicide single men are more likely to
have mental health problems single men
they're more likely to die with
depression
um there is biological needs for men and
women they need each other that's how we
designed the majority of men haven't
reproduced historically as in that cabin
had kids and what do you mean like only
only 40 of men have reproduced
historically they're the ones that have
survived so I I know I said outside of
reproduction yeah so so the whole point
is the info like I understand that men
would prefer to have a partner but the
whole point of society would keep on
going on if women and disappeared
tomorrow wouldn't be the same for
I I think it depends on how you define
whether the survival if it's based on
yet just getting things done absolutely
but if it's based on having emotional
kind of security I don't think anybody
can I don't think here any human can
literally live a happy life if they
don't have a connection with the
opposite so it was somebody I love it
that's a female point of view like
because because there's a whole group of
men that are walking away from
relationships it's called mgtow and a
lot of the like
the ones
the difference but men is men going
their own way they're walking away from
relationships because they just don't
think women bring much to the table
anymore is it that women don't bring
much or they can't get the woman that
they want what percent of women are
virgins and 22 and want to get married
and traditional nowadays they're not all
men want but I think that's great but I
don't think all men need that I mean
historically that that is always what
men have wanted yeah I get that but I
don't think now that's the essential
criteria of what you you want and what
you need what you need is you do need
companionship men don't have an outlet
they can't talk to their friends about
things they can't talk to anybody about
their emotions when they feel like you
can talk to your friends what's better
talking to your friends or talking to
your woman about your emotions I'm gonna
just say this and I want to just like
I'm gonna look to the camera and say
guys do not talk to your girlfriend
about your emotions why do guys say this
I feel like that's an
that's a red pill tour
you have to disagree but I think when
you when you find a real one
yeah so there's there's some things that
men are supposed to be in women's eyes
and there's some things that are never
supposed to see and your woman's not
supposed to see you cry I don't care if
your family passes away you're not
supposed to cry and it's not because
you're not emotional you come acquired
to me come across to your boy come and
cry to your sister you're gonna cry to
your woman they sometimes like
women it's not their fault they just
like hypergamous inside their bodies
like they thought when she you know that
thing where Mom said get the ick they
won't even understand why they do it but
seeing you crying will just knock down
your face dripping have you seen your
face studies
are there studies that have confirmed
this too but there's different men lose
respect for men after they see them cry
trust me I I think once you have find a
real one though like a like a proper
ride or die then it don't matter you
won't know she's a writer that you cry
are you willing to risk it
yeah yeah I just I just know that what
she requires for me is not seeing me cry
and Noble woman requires that my mom
doesn't require seeing me her son cry
like it's not it's it doesn't mean men
cannot cry like I'm saying cry to your
friend go and speak to your boy about
I'm not saying to you not to speak I
wouldn't cry with my boys how often do
you cry in front of your girl oh that
means like very rarely how often how
long have you been together coming up to
a year okay so so in a year already
[Music]
and that's what I'm saying like even
that in itself I was like not even a
family bereavement just and I want to
say it to to men because women don't
understand why they do a lot of things
no but I think there's a difference
between being vulnerable and being
emotional we hate emotional emotional
just means you're overreacting
emotionally to a situation that you're
now removing logic so if a guy gets
really emotional like I I've been in a
situation where a guy gets so emotional
about maybe something on social media
whatever it is he loses his masculinity
he's overreacting that's a
disproportionate response but
vulnerability is opening up and that
leads to connection the question the
question is at what point so at what
point is crying too much it's just when
it's disproportionate to the situation
because you know what's disproportional
he doesn't we do exactly exactly so no
no but this is a bit and it's based off
of what how we feel about masculinity no
but at what point and that's the thing
like it's confusing to men because every
woman's different based on how she feels
and also it's
at what point is it too much I think
there's objective measures of what would
be too much like if it's a family a
bereavement I think most women would
understand but if it's like
um you know your cat's upset and then
you get a lot of things what if he's
just really stressed out at work yes
disproportionate response to cry over
stress at work that would be
disproportionate and Men this is why I
said do not cry because about worse
because crying already work can make you
cry like that you can I'm sure you've
had very stressful days
yeah I mean yeah yeah yeah you lost your
you know I mean like so once you tell me
I can cry you don't get to tell me what
I can cry about like so I come to you
and I'm like it's not something we tell
you it's just your masculine energy will
dictate what makes you cry if you should
figure out yourself it doesn't dictate
to you your level masculinity will just
dictate that it doesn't dictate to you
what gives you the ick so that's what
I'm trying to say to you yeah I'm a Fool
like
um I can cry because I've lost my
channel and I put lots of work into
building something and there's an Empire
and now it's lost and you don't
understand how that makes me feel and
it's really doing something to me and
you're like you're just as YouTube what
are you worrying about it's Instagram
but you don't know what I built so I
start crying over this because I was
looking at the I was looking at the
media accompanying the Empire I was
going to build in the network and you
just looking at me like get over it if
if she gets to ick over that and and she
understands the context behind it like
this is my life I've built this thing it
means a lot to me and I'm upset by it if
she gets to ick over that then she's not
the right girl no but once again what
you're saying is yeah but like that
sounds nice but I just don't think it's
honest it's not it's not like like it
sounds nice but in general women lose
respect for men when we see them cry and
we can pretend we don't but it's just
it's so what would I say to someone just
cry and risk it all I already know
something she may she may not why would
I want to test it out I just know men
are not supposed to be crying in front
of their girl for no reason and that
might be a reason to me but the fact
there's no reason but she said to me you
can cry but you can only cry about
certain things and I'm not going to tell
you what those certain things your
masculinity needs to let you know what
you're allowed to cry about just don't
cry bro
it's not nothing it's same with women
there's going to be certain things that
we do that's levels to it there's levels
to it and but vulnerability and
emotional it's not the same thing you
can still be wrong
I want you to keep your relationships
I'm gonna say cry don't cry out like
loud but I am proportion I had the
perfect amount that only each woman
knows and guess
context is everything in life I mean I
know everything's black and white so at
the end of the day if it's something
that's a big deal yeah and you're upset
by it and then she's not there for you
then that's the wrong girl get rid of
her move on because once you find the
girl that's really down for you then
none of that's gonna matter you know
what I mean because context will prevail
and all of that stuff is really great
for short-term dating and stuff but if
we're talking long-term connections
you're going to bury children together
God forbid you might bury your parents
together you're trying to tell me you
can't cry in those moments this is great
for short-term flings this mentality but
if you want a long-term connection you
might have a still birth you and your
man's just been like no no no can't be
done no life happens so we're taking I
mean it's just like as a woman for me I
always want a guy that is calm and
strong even in horrible situations so
like and this isn't pretty but this is
just me being honest one of the reasons
I respect like all of the men that I
respect the most I've barely ever seen
them cry
and
I just think it's it's a lot of times as
women we mean well and we want to be
there for men but I don't think we can
I think it's short term yeah it makes
sense but I don't know my dad cries when
like I leave the country for a couple of
months or stuff like that and
um maybe because I've seen he cries when
you leave the country yeah he cries I
think it's just the agent where I'm from
Pakistan so he like just not seeing me
every day kind of affects him and stuff
and like you know so he'll cry when I if
I'm going back to Dubai he'll cry or
whatever it is and uh but he's he's
still a very masculine man and I just
think when it's proportional and it's in
line with your masculinity it's fine but
when it's it's masculine man and he
cries every time you leave the country
yeah he does bless him I'll be honest
with you just as you said that Paul I
just thought about my dad I've never
seen him cry my whole life I just I just
can't I don't know your dad personally
so I'm not trying to offend you I just
can't imagine a masculine man crying
every time his daughter leaves the
country he cries every time like he gets
emotional at the idea of me leaving the
country Pearl I've spoke about my dad
before and how high in regard to hold
him he was um Diplomat and he's the
chief um back home and he's been through
so much and I just think he's never
cried like never never do you know you
actually have no idea what it is to be a
chief and to run I mean I'm just
thinking the most masculine archetypes
they don't like they don't cry no I've
seen him stressed out I've seen my dad
stressed out like and I'm coming to her
and I'm like but
ugh
him cry no they just there's some things
you just do as well for other people as
well that is not attractive but I don't
think it should be a rule I think it
should be you let your own masculinity
dictate whether you cry or not no
because masculinity takes you not
actually crying it's actually femininity
which creates crying because to build
your masculine energy so you cry less
wrong I'm not telling men to hold it in
no but you what I'm doing is I'm saying
to men
don't get tricked out your position yeah
do not go and cry to your misses when
you have friends where natural fact you
could be building more bro code and
building them more Bromance as you want
to call it yeah this strengthens your
Unity if you've never done it with your
boys I suggest you pick your closest boy
and you guys start bonding you do not go
and get your girl who's supposed to look
at you like a Superman the guy that
protects me how are you going to protect
her now when you're crying I'm trying to
and the reason I'm trying to say is
because she doesn't mean to do it it's
not her fault it's just in her body it's
not like say if your dad did want to cry
and get upset would he go to your mum or
would he go to his boys
safely did God forbid safety was an
incident that made him really get upset
would you rather would would the
connection that your mum and dad have
built is it better for him to go to your
mom or is it better to him go to a
friend even now I couldn't imagine my
mom wanted to see my dad cry like I just
because I know
what do you think would be better for
him
to go to my mom right because I wouldn't
want him to go to other Chiefs and to be
seen this week because they would see
him as weak exactly go look at the chief
of all chiefs coming to us and crying so
what does that tell you about long-term
connections what are they built on no
but well I'm trying to say trust there's
a trust element with your vulnerability
at this point it would have him looking
weak to the other to the other tribes
right so you don't want to be it's more
okay it's more important to be seen
masculine outside of the home and to the
world than it is supposed to see
masculine to your words it's changing
that's what I'm saying it's changing I
feel like that's generational no but
like okay I'll be honest with you even
now yeah you don't want to be the the
guy that's crying to the girl and and
doing the r b love singing bro because
the guy which ain't do the guy that's
doing the drilling them he's blowing
backs out bro and this is the thing I
don't want I don't want you to be crying
in the rain like like Ray J bro
and you're you're a boss you come to
your boss and you start crying to your
boss because you're so stressed out
because I can't cry to my wife wouldn't
your boss be like take that to your home
don't bring your tears in my office
okay I understand what you're saying
yeah 50-year marriage you're probably
gonna cry at some point right but the
point is
it as women it's it's dishonest to tell
men to make that a habit occasions
occasionally occasionally occasionally
every couple but every woman doesn't
know what her point is so you don't know
at what point exactly you're going to be
turned off by it and I don't know
exactly what point I'll be here so so
it's easier just to tell men you know
what avoid that with your girl do that
with your boys if you can because it's
confusing to men because some girls they
see you cry like there's girls that have
said I saw him cry once and I couldn't
look at him the same ever again happen
one time
there's some girls multiple times that
it'll take why was he crying I don't
know yeah so PO let me tell you
something I'm gonna you know I'm gonna
we're gonna open up a little bit here I
don't do too much okra I know I'm
getting a little bit better with some
stuff so tell him some stuff so
uh my first true love I would say oh it
must have been together about five years
uh
um I was I could tell the story you've
seen it but I was I was stabbed when I
was younger very badly I was on Live
support machine
um people seen the pictures and stuff I
was hooked up the machines and stuff
the girl that said she would never leave
me ever when I was hooked up and I
couldn't walk when I cried and when I
when I had the the cafeteria inside of
me the [ __ ] bag all of that stuff yeah
something happened after that I'm
telling you something like something got
changed the Superman that I wasn't even
though I survived and even though I was
whatever she's happy now she's mad she
got her kids and the rest of it and I'm
happy for them were cool but trust me on
this man you could I was on my deathbed
I was hooked up to machines and the girl
that was hooked up the girl that was
standing next to me holding my hand that
said she'll never leave me still left me
men you have to understand this are you
sure it's due to that or do you think it
could be other barriers it could be
other variables but what I will say is
that
afterwards I found out she wanted to
leave me but obviously this stuff that
happened created Created something in it
and I just know that there's some parts
of being a man that after you step after
his past vulnerability now it's like yo
dependent your dependency kicked the
hell out yeah and she said to herself I
can't do this right and
when you feel that like you're not
supposed to kick out because of because
I'm I need you now you know what I mean
like I'm effed up bro I can't even you
know what I mean is that is more her
because because I feel like what you're
doing right now is what people do on
social media too much and that's
generalization that you're based in your
experiences like a girl nobody nobody
nobody essentially you're taking your
experience with your ex and then saying
that you're saying it's the same thing
like okay not we know not all we we know
that we don't have to say with every
everything it's not every single person
but in general women don't like to see
men cry yeah like like women like
masculine men the most sought after guys
are like tough they're not I'm not
trying to say that this is for like ah
like I'm you know what I opened up when
I get told that
I don't want to be rude but he was
arguing to me like a girl bro I opened
up a story to show you an example I
could give you other examples and other
people are you not trying to say to you
I could literally give you examples let
me give you another one women don't care
about what you go through bro like you
might think they do that's why she was
talking about work
um she was gauging what it's okay to cry
about at work like you can lose it all
tomorrow in it yeah go and start crying
to girls about you lost it all and
you're not the man you ain't got the car
you had now you've you're not an
apartment no more you've gone to one
room and you will discover how many
girls all of a sudden don't want to hear
stories again
I don't care bro I don't know what
that's fact I'll give you an example
guys and girls crying on the street look
look up yes what is the Public's
reaction
they stop for the women they don't for
the men you know what it is for me yeah
I like the thing that just grinds my
gear here is that same thing with the
feminist type thing like I just hate
when people generalize in that's that's
just it so it doesn't matter the
scenario or what you're saying it's just
I don't like generalization in general
however you get a load of women online
just talking [ __ ] about men because
they're generalizing their share
experience with one man and then saying
oh all men are trash that [ __ ] pisses me
off as well how is it a general how do
we have a conversation about anything
about General truths about Society if we
can't speak in generalities
and so if there are studies that say in
general women lose respect for men when
they see them cry okay so there's
studies that back this up
we can't we can't talk about that I I
hear it I hear it but like I said it's
context and everything you know what I
mean so dude you you want every time we
talk about anything to say but not all
like I'm just asking because I get this
a lot
so if we don't ever dealing how do we
ever come to
um to a general consensus if we don't
deal in yeah that's what I'm saying like
how would we have a conversation about
relationships in general if we don't
talk about in general we'll have to talk
about it's hard to no but the thing is
everything in life is General it's not
so I think whenever we speak we know
it's not all so sometimes people have to
say stuff like they'll be like um it's
not all yes we know it's not all women
but I think we've come to a general
consensus when we're speaking we're
speaking so we have to say modern women
right they have to say some women it
becomes this thing where I think we have
a level of intelligence that when we all
know we're not speaking about everybody
like we shouldn't keep having to do this
and when we do it with a man this is
something I do with women because they
want to keep moving the goal posts we
should just know that it's not all men
it's not all women if we have to keep
doing that it's because the the
conversation is getting derailed we
cannot ever come to a general consensus
or anything in life unless we do not use
an average yeah and we need to get an
average or we need to get a percentage
or something so and and the example you
used with men are trash and if there was
data that said 80 percent of men were
committing crimes against women okay but
when it's five two percent you know it's
not the same exactly but women
generalize and say oh men oh the the
difference is that in general most women
lose respect for men when they cry in
general most men aren't trash
once one's false one's true
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible